now talking of hanging out with big
musical stars ed Sheeran the Galway girl
video yeah so how did that happen so she
did you know him already
no I didn't know him but we have a lot
of mutual friends and friends from
Suffolk which is where he grew up and
all your friends and New Zealand and
things like that and I was a one night I
was a with my friend in London and the
cast and agent who was casting for the
video just emailed me and said Harry do
you want to be in an edge here in video
I was like yeah right
and it was gonna be on my birthday um
12th of April just you know yeah and I
did it and it was brilliant and he
filmed the whole thing he had like a
camera on a rake and we just ran around
Galway for an entire and ie and he had
like because he's I mean he's huge
everywhere but he's beloved in Ireland
like everyone loves him so much and and
so all of Galway just like followed us
around from place to place what the
tattoo in the video the Galway grill
yeah so that he really did get he got
that really tattooed he did yeah I got
your handle it's my handwriting
Wow so yeah rosid on him did you know I
was very very nervous about it so I
practiced for about half an hour before
they actually tattooed and that's what
you came up with
[Laughter]
did you mean to do the bad spelling no
it wasn't my idea to do the bad name to
people at his gig that I just misspelled
the word girls but I didn't and the the
tour manager in Dublin we had had a few
drinks during the show because he did
two shows and Dublin after we did the
music video and the tour manager was
gone by and he was like you know what
it'd be gas if you misspelled the word
girl and tattooed something else onto
him and so we did Galway grill instead
and they got a tattoo artist to come in
at like 12 o'clock at night to Dublin
during a birthday priority that was
being had in in town and they just kick
your door but he came in and he was
terrified like this poor fellow was
happened to late a two-on-two edge
Sharon's arm with the arm that he plays
the guitar with so he must meet I've
been told he's really wrong now was
there a Galway grill that actually
benefited from this there was a
[Music]
you